in our series a more perfect union we
aim to show you that what unites us as
Americans is certainly far greater than
what divides us recently nothing has
kept us more apart than this coronavirus
at least physically anyway but some
students in the nation's heartland are
turning to our largely lost art to reach
seniors whose families cannot visit chip
Reid has a story windows are meant to
look out not keep people in but
sometimes social distancing turns
everyday events into a trip through the
looking-glass
everything from Earth's to birthdays
engagements and one community used a
craned help family visit seniors forced
to stay inside and in Iowa spirits
soared even higher when the local
student council serenaded residents here
at Bickford Senior Living in Sioux City
and found a way to touch those inside is
he super special to you oh for sure oh
thank you sir thank you thank you my
friend you feel the same way Mike oh
yeah yeah that feels good to hear that
yeah I'm really excited too
Mike Boggs and Lincoln Collings newfound
friendship is separated by nearly five
decades and for now this one window he
saw yeah I'm gonna tear up you're pretty
soon when the high school freshmen heard
that coronavirus kept Mike's family from
visiting Lincoln found another way
Lincoln picked up his pen to let the 63
year old stranger with early onset
dementia know that he wasn't forgotten
do you want me to read one of them
anyway this is out of control I can't
even buy toilet paper Mike I bet you've
read
that letter more than once I've read it
about 50 times probably yeah the Paris
letters are part of an old-fashioned pen
pal program launched by Lincoln's school
do you think this is something that
could and should go on all across the
nation
the sioux city students now visit their
pen pals each week planting flowers and
on windows sidewalks and on the faces of
residents inside and their families
outside over the phone
Mike reads Lincoln's letters to his wife
packed
there's something about handwriting yes
as a third grade teacher I'm a strong
proponent of cursive handwriting Pat was
surprised to learn that she had a hand
in the writing that's now doing so much
for her husband he said remember Lincoln
calling and I said well sure I do he was
in my third grade class he said well
we're going to be pen pals I didn't
remember any teachers from back then
except for mrs. Boggs just mrs. Boggs
yeah now Lincoln and Mike are making new
memories well it's just like having a
having another son and when they're
finally together Mike knows what's next
in their friendship
just giving him a big ol bear hug and
say enough everything's gonna be okay
now for CBS this morning I'm chip Reid
Lincoln and Mike oh I love their story
and you know Tony nobody writes letters
anymore we're so busy texting emailing
we don't even call so just to get a
personal letter I think means so much
means so much more yeah no I agree
completely it's a beautiful thing and
and you know this virus has the longer
people have lived the harder they're hit
by this and you you spend all day
looking on a window you can forget that
the world outside is remembering you as
well and so it's great to see that as
kids walk up and say hello and you're
right write a letter how charming